what's the difference between
marxian economics
and marxist
political ideology
the gap between the two the overlap the
differences what the real the real
foundation of marx's political
philosophy was the economic argument
that there would be a tendency for the
rate of profit to fall
and that tendency for the rate of profit
or fall would lead to
capitalists battening down on workers
harder paying them less than their
subsistence
uh i'll revolt by workers against this
and then you would get socialism on the
other side so his
he that what he called the tendency for
the right of prophet to fall played a
critical role in his explanation for why
socialism would have to come about he
was saying it would have to come about
or is it a good thing for it to come
about um
he had assured but he was trying to say
it must
so you if you look at marx in the
history of radical thought he was
preceded by what were called utopian
socialists
sansamon even the cadburys company came
out of utopian socialist
and they had an idea about a perfect
society in the future where people were
properly rewarded were treated as human
beings rather than cogs in a machine and
all this sort of stuff and they said
socialism should come about because it's
it treats humans better than capitalism
does
marx said i can prove that socialism
must come about
so he preferred he had a utopian vision
of a future society but he thought he
could prove that it had to come about
and the the proof
relied critically upon
tendency for the rate of profit to fall
and that relied upon labor being the
only source of profit
what what was his utopian view so this
this idea from each according to his
ability to each according to his needs
yeah is that
the utopian
i think it's utopian in the context of
our modern world
it it it says that you
you rather than being rewarded like jeff
bezos gets enormous fortune uh you get
what you need
not what you want
necessarily all what all needs is
fulfilled it was it was a vision of
utopia where you could be a fisherman in
the morning
a poet in the afternoon
and a chef at night okay that's
paraphrasing one of his phrases so he
did have a utopian vision of a future
society and he did think human
creativity would be much much greater
under socialism than it was under
capitalism he was wrong
you